there's a British thing where they'll
say okay so like my friend's name is
Teresa and her mom would do something
which she would add an r that isn't
there at the end of her name if it was
before a vowel in the next word so if
she's saying Teresa and Andrea her
sister shout out to Teresa she would say
Teresa ran Andrea but in a British
accent Teresa and Andrea yeah yeah okay
there's an increasing tendency among
speakers of British English to insert an
R sound so that Law and Order become Law
and Order and China animals becomes
China animals
linguists call this intrusive R because
the I was never historically part of the
world wait what a weird example of China
animals I'm glad somebody's finally
talking about China
Google is like you're gonna read about
the China animals today is that even a
real phrase would it be Chinese animals
China animals What are China animals
this is what they're talking about in
England